أنا كوبر هافنر وسأقدم
لك جولة في المنزل الذي نشأت فيه في
Playboy Mansion ، نحن في غرفة الأفلام ،
هذه الغرفة هي غرفة الشاحنة ، لذا فهذه واحدة
من أروع الأماكن في المنزل هذا
هو  مجرد المدخل اللامتناهي إذا كانت
الصور وستجد أنها مجرد لعبة تجسس
لأي شخص يمكن أن تتخيله على الإطلاق
ميك جاغر في القاعة الكبرى في Ringo
Starr ، لقد كانت مجرد مغامرة الأولاد النهائية
التي
تعرفها لدي  كان لديّ مسدسات نيرف ، كما تعلمون ،
كنت أركض مع أصدقائي الذين
تعلمون أنني كنت أركض عبر الغابة ،
كان الأمن يعمل بعد أن كنت مثل ماني ،
كان من المضحك أن يربي والديّ من
منظور أوروبي جدًا حول
الجنس والعري لم يكن هناك أي شيء
لم يكن من المحرمات أنه موجود في الكثير
من الأسر الأمريكية ، أتذكر أنني
نشأت وأفكر كيف يمكن
لأشخاص آخرين أن يعتقدوا أن العنف أكثر
ملاءمة من العري ولكن هذه هي
الطريقة التي نشأت بها وليس هذا هو
الطريق كثيرًا  من الأمريكيين كانوا موسيقى الراي  هناك الكثير
من الأشخاص الموجودين في وضعي
الذين ينتمون إلى
خلفية ذات امتياز مالي تعرفهم ولديهم
اسم ويعتقدون أنه يمنحهم
التحقق من الصحة ويعتقدون أن هذا يجعلني
مهمًا إذا كان بإمكاني أن أكون الرجل الموجود في
الزاوية المقابلة  من هذا القبيل ،
فأنا فخور بنفسي ،
سأكون بالتأكيد شخصًا ما
لبقية حياتي
مرتبطًا بالرجل الذي كان نوعًا ما لديه
الملعقة الفضية ، والكثير من الناس
يجعلني نوعًا ما أرغب في العمل بجدية أكبر من أجلها